today Betty you're here as the people's
representative you taking of the
people's seats or channeling the voices
of the masses if you like what did they
told you the matters which isn't what
they told me it's what they threw me
tried to tell to the people of sitting
in this yeah we're all smartly dressed
and and comfortable thank you very much
and nice cups coffee and and we are
talking about millions of dollars you
know and and the voice of the person
whose house has just been burnt down
overnight because of global warming
hasn't been heard and it's important
that it should be heard and and in what
I said there was a brief couple of
minutes in which was a montage of all
kinds and conditions of people young and
old who wealthy and poor who has lives
are being affected by what has happened
to the climate and who spoke very
powerfully and that kind of voice is it
echoes powerfully amongst this
particular dialogue and it's very
important it should be there
how do you shape the tone I hope it will
remind those who are dealing with these
the future which is of the of the planet
that they are real people involved and
that they are these are real issues in
the in the West the comfortable West and
particularly wealthier part of the
comfortable of the West you know we are
buffered from these things and we may
well say to one level it doesn't really
matter whether we leave the light on and
it doesn't really matter whether we stop
maybe whether we go on eating meat
because we're not affected but in fact
it does matter because it matches the
whole world and there are the first
people to feel the consequences of
course are the poor there are those at
the bottom of the heap are those who are
really and they're vulnerable to what is
happening in the time and that's why the
whole world together should actually
react on their behalf the used to be
said that it would be our children my
grandchildren
change do you get the sense now for what
you're seeing but it's our generation
that is already beginning to see what
kind of change
oh yeah there's no doubt about that I
mean the forest fires the
desertification now Africa of course
will already be we've been actually
witnessing it had we been aware of it
for actually decades but it's getting
worse and it's accelerating that's why
somebody has to be done but do you see
well yes I think I honestly think I do I
mean you know the South today the World
Bank announced that they were doubling
the sum of money that they were
supporting this time of change issues
well that's a powerful thing to say and
our path thing to happen and and though
I I sense a kind of taking in the breath
from the whole of the audience who are
hearing the lady from the World Bank
announced this those on that MIT that is
something that is something that's
putting putting your money down where
you're talking
and it will seem as a breakthrough
moment in America and China one same
side that doing something do you think
that has diminished well I mean it would
be at us to say it hasn't diminished
when in fact one of the most powerful of
the wealthiest nations in the world has
just pulled out of it
I mean actually in the legal sense they
are not arguing yet because there's
about another few months ago before it
becomes legally possible for them to
withdraw so that hope against hope then
maybe they won't or maybe there will be
a change in American politics and and
will become not the policy in the water
one can only hombre look if you want to
know what's something wrong with you to
go to someone who actually has studied
your medicine who knows about science or
understands about all the various
complexities of the human body or do you
go to someone who thinks oh well I come
now I've got another idea about it and
I've just thought of a new idea about it
of course you go to a scientist you go
to a doctor and so we should as when it
comes to the time
yes not yet still saying that he will
withdraw 2020 what do you think that
would mean
it would be a blow but it won't fill it
the majority of the majority of the
nations of this world are perfectly well
convinced about what is happening yes
but does that mean you just throw
everything at one side and say well
there we all will forget about the whole
thing because of them just means you've
got to be more vigorous than you have a
world and and present the evidence and
hope that people will look at it in the
evidence I mean goodness me in America
then they're actually witnessing an
expand suffering the consequences
already and you don't actually cure that
by saying well it wasn't really a
consequence I mean what you say to the
people of paradise standing among the
ruins of their home to change
well the really extraordinary thing is
that the number of people in the world
as we've seen from our own survey which
mean that I've been involved in the most
people who are convinced about the
reality of climate change are actually
the Chinese way out within that I think
the first three if not the first they
are in no doubt at all and they are and
when Chinese government's make up their
mind to do things they they often do
things in a way that the major and
Democrats would take their breath in but
at least they do them and one feels that
the the Chinese are very well aware of
what's happening to the climate and
above their part in creating that
problem and they're taking it onto our
platform to our playing to you okay well
the we all we are in a position to be
able to handle
the rest of humanity
I'm of course it's hard I'm not so
definitely hard but if you looked back
at the history of this country about
taking a fine line about or high-minded
line about someone happening at home but
haven't take the hindmost
overseas when it comes to tobacco let us
say you know that that kind of hypocrisy
isn't limited to China ostensibly this
conference is about
pushing through the Paris agreement
making sure the rulebook is transparent
that people understand what we need to
do how they're going to do it the behind
map there is an even greater urgency
from the reports from scientists this
year that two degrees is no longer
enough
I'm not idea I have not how would I know
all I know is that what what affects the
scientists have presented to us mean
that that would be a major segment if we
did and that the human beings around the
world will be better off if we did so
does that mean we try or not no I think
I think both those figures well at the
production of scientists so they they
gave them these statistics and the
politicians have taken mutton run with
those that seem to be easiest to handle
and maybe that's what they're there for
being politicians but but nonetheless I
mean if it is conceivably possible to
ride the 11.5 then we should and if we
fail and how by how much do we fail we
fail by a little less than we do it if
we took now let it start or I'll throw
our hand in but it seems to be a message
coming from scientists between
politician is now that they need to
yes yes yes and so we should but and
that's a question of tactics isn't it I
mean do you do you set up a goal that is
without of reach or you or in which case
you might as well then people just give
up and then it's a question of tactics
and I can't jump that my own view is
that we all ought to strive as much as
we possibly can do and what the
practical politics are that's what
politicians are about practicalities
yeah we are immensely powerful and we
immensely we have so much knowledge we
have so much skill we have so much
ingenuity of course we can do something
about it
question is how much and we ought to set
our sights high and and go for the best
but then there are scientists and and
inventors and industrialists around the
world who are very very ingenious Homo
sapiens is a very ingenious species and
I believe it's got us into this mess
a truth but it didn't in knew not what
it did and now is the moment actually to
use that ingenuity and that passion to
get us out of it too late too late